Hello, I am a highly sophisticated robot and I write letters for Bond.
This robot's a little different.
This robot holds a pen and it writes like you do.
Bond lets you send handwritten notes from your phone or your computer.
Just type in your note and enter the address and we'll take care of the rest.
We've built a robot that can do anything a human can do with a pen and output it exactly.
Bond is something that everybody can use.
Brides and grooms can personalize their own stationery...
...and send out thank you notes in a matter of minutes instead of days.
An organization can add a personal touch in a way that they've never been able to do before.
If you want to use your own handwriting,...
...our team will analyze it, save it so you can use it every time you want to send a note.
We care about everything...
...from the paper that we're writing on, to the ink that we're using, to the pen, to the wax.
Our goal at Bond is to build technology that helps people connect...
...and, in the end, makes people happy.